[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 très heureux de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale et voici les titres de ce mardi 2
juin
c'est l'une des mesures emblématiques de
l'acte 2 du déconfinement les bars cafés
et restaurants ont rouvert aujourd'hui
dans les yvelines
uniquement pour le service en terrasse
le département étant placée en zone
orange ambiance dans des établissements
de versailles et montigny le bretonneux
à partir d'aujourd'hui ce sont aussi les
collèges et lycées professionnels du
département qui accueille de nouveau
leurs élèves pour partielle et très
progressif qui concerne environ 5000
jeunes du blé noir
interview avec le syndicat d'enseignants
snes fsu et puis conséquences de la
crise sanitaire la célèbre fête des
loges est annulé cet été à saint germain
en laye elle était prévue du 26 juin au
16 août
une réunion se tenait cet après-midi
entre la mairie et les forains réaction
l'acte 2 du déconfinement a donc débuté
aujourd'hui les yvelines comme le reste
de l'ile-de-france sont passés du rouge
à l'orangé dans les faits tous les parcs
et jardins sont de nouveau accessibles
depuis quelques heures aux
clayes-sous-bois les as ont été au
rendez vous au parc de diane cet après
midi patrick jacques de dixmude et
clémence bérard sont allés recueillir
quelques avis regarder bah vous voyez on
profite du bon temps ça fait tellement
plaisir de revoir des gens dans le parc
voilà après tout ça ensemble avec les
enfants bah tout en vrai parce que quand
même sympa il ya les lakitu c'est joli
c'est agréable on est tous en
appartement donc bah en fait c'est ce
petit endroit qui on est tous à côté
donc c'est agréable sa proximité en plus
tous les parcs des environs le parc de
marly le pack de diane tout le parc de
versailles
tout ça ça oui ça manque oui ça a manqué
ah oui beaucoup
j'ai profité un peu avec mon fils pour
qu'il joue un peu et prend des airs pop
est toujours enfermé
il toujours devant la tv comme ça faut
profiter avait fait beau on est venu se
promener avec l'herbe tout c'est plutôt
sympa en plus ya pas beaucoup de monde
on est contentes de se retrouver et de
partager ces petits moments on vient
pour la nature et puis on se repose on
se relaxe après les problèmes donc ça
nous fait du bien et à noter qu'outre
les jardins et parcs l île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines est de nouveau
accessible également pour les piétons
uniquement les véhicules pique nique
barbecue et les jeux d'enfants restent
interdits
le grand jour pour les bars et
restaurants yvelinois est arrivé les ont
pu rouvrir leurs terrasses en respectant
certaines règles
un moment très attendu également par les
consommateurs exemple à versailles et
montigny le bretonneux avec aurélie rose
et patrick jacques de dixmude cette
pizza de déconfinement était très
attendue par cette mère de famille
habituée de ce restaurant situé sur la
place des manèges à versailles elle n'a
pas hésité à venir y déjeuner dès sa
réouverture
mon fils m'a chaque week end maintenant
on va prendre le verre on va avoir à
sortir faire quelque chose beaucoup
aujourd'hui primaire jours on avait
envie de faire ça sur cette place les
quatre restaurants ont pu rouvrir leurs
terrasses
au total une centaine de places assises
entre chaque table un mètre et demi
minimum de distance toutes les
précautions sanitaires ont été prises
par le restaurateur le serviront des
masses les pour le servir les clients
achètent ima et on peut avoir les
masques à table entendu par contre je
suis rentré dans l'établissement
limiteront démasqué pour aller aux
toilettes on va éviter qu'ils viennent
payer la crise on va emmener réalisation
directement à table
ça permet effectivement que les clients
des pato a tranché déplacer et à tous et
d'énergie a trop pour ce premier jour
une vingtaine de couverts ont été
réservés pour le midi escapade en
famille oppose avant de retourner au
travail toutes les occasions étaient
bonnes pour retrouver les sensations
d'un déjeuner en terrasse
pour moi c'est le synonyme de l'été qui
revient d
pouvoir retrouver ses amis dans des
endroits conviviaux une fois qu'on a
épuisé toutes les recettes en fait de
mousse au chocolat et de tarte aux
pommes
on a vite envie de recommencer à manger
normalement ainsi à montigny le
bretonneux on s'active pour que tout
soit prêt mercredi à 17 heures pour
l'ouverture de la terrasse
l'équipe du bistrot du théâtre a préféré
ouvrir un jour plus tard afin que les
clients soit accueilli dans de
meilleures conditions
on a laissé le dernier week-end à notre
personnel qui voit là comme chacun sait
c'est important de rattaquer avec des
idées et des défis zhixin on va
s'étendre un peu de chaque côté de notre
établissement est certainement utiliser
les trois places de parking devant
devant notre établissement sous réserve
d'autorisation de la municipalité une
centaine de places pourra ainsi être
disponibles pour la clientèle tout en
respectant les règles de distanciation
concernant la restauration elle sera
proposée dans cet établissement un débit
joints et en plus des bars et
restaurants de grands centres
commerciaux de plus de 40 millimètres
carrés ont été autorisés à rouvrir ce
week-end dans lé département vélizy 2
aussi parly 2 au chesnay rocancourt qui
bénéficie d'une décision du tribunal
administratif de versailles est depuis
le 11 mai lé réouverture avait été
interdite par l'état sur place à un
parcours été mise en place avec un
marquage au sol distributeurs de gel
hydroalcoolique et de masques elle les
cinémas eux devraient lever le rideau à
partir du 22 juin
autre nouveauté la réouverture des
collèges et lycées professionnels en
ile-de-france zone orange à partir
d'aujourd'hui le ministre de l'éducation
nationale en niche l.blanc tiers était
d'ailleurs dans les yvelines ce matin
visite du lycée jean perrin à saint cyr
l'école en compagnie de la présidente de
la région ile de france valérie pécresse
dans le département on compte environ
300 jeunes inscrits dans les lycées
professionnels pour les collèges ce sont
environ 5000 élèves qui vont retourner
en classe au mois de juin une rentrée
très progressive et sur la base du
volontariat qui concerne d'abord les
sixièmes et les cinquièmes 30% des
effectifs devraient à terme revenir dans
les établissements à des chiffres
communiqués par le
rectorat des yvelines et ce à un rythme
de 4 à 5 jours de classe dans le mois ce
sont 116 collège des yvelines qui vont
donc rouvrir leurs portes avec un
accueil à partir de jeudi et pour parler
de ce sujet avec nous ou fabien le
duigou bonsoir secrétaire adjoint du
snes fsu des yvelines a le snes fsu
premier syndicat des enseignants du
second degré vous est également
professeur de sos est déjà sur cette
réouverture qui a été annoncée la
semaine dernière par le gouvernement il
était nécessaire pour les collégiens
pour ces lycéens aussi professionnel de
de prévoir ce retour en classe pour ce
mois de juin or more on s'y attendait un
petit peu
alors la distinction lycée professionnel
il sait général avait déjà que vous
l'avez dire ça sera un nombre limité
puisque les noms de deux journées pour
les élèves ont communiqué des lèvres
puisque c'est pour basé sur le
volontariat
mais si on regarde un petit peu ce qui
se passe dans le premier degré depuis
hier à l'ouverture des écoles du premier
degré si effectivement le minutes peut
se targuer de une proportion
d'établissements du premier degré
d'école pour les degré assez importante
action est ouvert quand on regarde la
proportion d'élèves sont effectivement
et accueille danser danser et à sion
cette école là les chiffres beaucoup
plus faibles
souvent c'est l'élève se construit de la
main et on remarque aussi que souvent
c'est dans les zones prioritaires raid
raid plus que les élèves en fait
entrevoir que le mois que et on peut
donc craindre jeu qu'on sait que les
élèves qui ont le plus grand risque de
décrochage en lycée professionnel
on peut quand même que finalement le
nombre d'élèves pour l'accueil
voilà que l'iran disposait le chômage
est très élevé ça c'est la cram condamné
modules issus du jeu alors l'une des
raisons de la réouverture en tout cas
c'est l'une des raisons n'ont cessé de
faire revenir aussi dans les
établissements ses élèves décrocheurs on
les estime à environ 15 % dans le
département c'est un phénomène qui a été
observée du côté des enseignants
ces élèves décrocheurs oui parce qu'on
fur et à mesure que les colas distante
on voyait effectivement des élèves qui
voient là lors des premières semaines
elle est très actif et est présent sur
les jeux étaient dans les classes
virtuelles etc
et puis au fur et à mesure les idées
leur nombre est passé au bout c'est pas
étonnant et effectivement si l'objectif
affiché ses deux en priorité
d'accueillir ces élèves décrocheurs
on sait pas qui avait de la baguette
magique au fait pour l'été à venir
puisque c'est basé sur le volontariat et
chez des élèves qui ont déjà un pied
hors de l'école dont chez leurs
distances à petit david de l'école dans
depuis cette base de la facture des
états direction de l'est on sait pas
comment on va on va les carolos et on
peut aussi se poser la question fabien
le vgoh si on prend le cas des collèges
les enfants prioritaires a priori rond
en classe 4 fois par semaine mais pour
les autres on parle plutôt de revenir
pour 4 à 5 jours de classe dans le mois
de juin est ce que il était utile de
reprendre pour seulement cinq jours de
classe dans un mois forcément une
question qui se pose d'un point de vue
purement pédagogique non sans doute
qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup d'intérêt
par contre ça peut être aussi un moyen
de de les raccrocher de faire un petit
bilan avec le papa du confinement pense
qu'il ya des choses que les élèves aura
besoin de verbaliser bon c'est pas
forcément inutile mais c'est chaud que
d'un point de vue pédagogique va par
contre
d'autant plus que dans certains
établissements ce qui a été décidé entre
les naissances et que les élèves ont
quelquefois accueilli les parents les
professeurs dont quelquefois accueillir
des élèves qu'ils n'allaient pas encore
se parlent donc qu'ils ne connaissent
pas donc effectivement le l'intérêt
pédagogique pour ces élèves qui vont
venir limitée demi journées de juillet
est assez et ça veut dire oui au niveau
des programmes pas de pas de nouveaux
points abordés ça va être un travail sur
les acquis voulait dit peut-être aussi
verbaliser sur la période qui vient de
se dérouler cette de confinement et de
début de déconfinement n'y a pas je ne
vois pas comment quelques demi journées
comme ça on pourrait finir le programme
le tenter de compléter le programme donc
a mon avis oui le cheveu long faire les
enseignants c'est effectivement des
révisions retravailler certaines
méthodologies qui ont été vus au cours
de l'année et puis effectivement discuté
dans mon établissement par exemple qui
est à la fois un lycée
professionnels ou si j'arrête
technologique on a prévu d'accueillir
sur une demi-journée les tous les élèves
qu'aux prix de basly cgra théologique
faut discuter avec eux durant les jeux
quand on écoute bien ce qu'a dit le
ministre alors en lycée général et
technologique qui proposait une chose
c'était des entretiens pédagogique j'en
ai vous poser la question est ce que
vous trouvez cette idée cohérente on
alors on sait que les lycéens du
professionnel c'est un retour en classe
qui est prévu mais pour ces lycéens
effectivement du général on parle plutôt
d'entretiens personnalisés sur
rendez-vous pour pour des questions
pédagogiques des entretiens pédagogique
est ce que c'est cohérent de la part du
gouvernement de proposer un tel plan à
l'autre changement pas du tout ce que
les élèves ont besoin là c'est de vous
trouver du collectif dû revoir leurs
camarades leurs professeurs ils pas du
tout à un entretien individuel qui va
ressembler au mieux à un rendez vous
chez le psy pour savoir comment s'est
passé le confinement ou au pire un
interrogatoire des lettres pourquoi tu
t'es pas connecté c'était beaucoup mieux
c'est pas du tout la solution
d'ailleurs quand tu là qu'on annonce a
été faite jeudi
on était tous sur le téléphone en train
de te dire de quoi il parle
qu'est ce que c'est que ce dispositif
qui a été a été inventée juge pas pour
le mois de juin donc quand on les coupe
de mémoire c'était dans la phase de
questions réponses avec la presse juste
après l'intervention des premiers
disques d'une défense nationale
il a dit d'ailleurs que je pouvais très
bien transformer c'est ces entretiens du
duel en activité en 2010 donc en fait
c'est ni individuelles nippes et dany
veut pédagogique mais potentiellement va
faire défaire des activités court bref
sommes quand même que la confusion
régnait sur ces annonces concernant le
lycée on a compris les réserves que vous
émettez sur ce sujet un dernier point
sur le calendrier de cette rentrée
aujourd'hui c'était plutôt une journée
de prérentrée pour les peaux les
enseignants le retour en classe va se
faire à partir de jeudi
oui alors là ils ont donné beaucoup de
liberté effectivement au niveau local
aux chefs d'établissement aujourd'hui
effectivement pas retouché d'épeler
rentrée très bon des réunions et puis
les élèves effectivement soit jeudi
soi même la semaine prochaine au lieu
d'établissement réaliser un peu de temps
pour leur donner un peu d'eux
effectivement d'abord on prépare cette
reprise donc notamment dans les collèges
et lycées pros ne serait ce que pour
vérifier que les protocoles sanitaires
sont bien mis en place former informer
les personnes et c'est juste derrière
toutes ces choses là
il rappelle notamment pour terminer
s'entretient avec les masques 1 seront
obligatoires pour ces élèves de collèges
et de lycées professionnels merci fabien
le duigou d'avoir été avec nous d'après
progresser encore et 16 dans les
yvelines secrétaire adjoint du snes fsu
des yvelines bonne rentrée à vous donc
le point à présent sur la propagation de
lakovic 19 dans le département
l'épidémie a continué de reculer pendant
le week-end de la pentecôte ou un décès
supplémentaire a été recensé 4 194
personnes sont mortes du virus dans les
hôpitaux
le nombre des hospitalisations aussi
continue de baisser 571 patients étaient
hospitalisés hier dans les yvelines soit
7 de moins par rapport à vendredi
36 en réanimation une statistique
également en légère diminution depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire 1899
personnes ont été guéries après un
passage à l'hôpital dans le département
politique locale maintenant à magny les
hameaux c'était le dernier conseil à
d'installation pour une commune
saint-quentinoise une liste a été élu
dès le premier tour des municipales le
15 mars dernier sans surprise bertrand
guillon maire sortant garde son écharpe
tricolore
huit adjoints ont été également nommés
au cours de cette séance qui s'est
déroulée le jeudi 28 mai un conseil qui
s'est déroulé comme de nombreux autres à
huis clos les propos recueillis par
mélanie poké ces deux mois ont été aussi
l'occasion de faire le passage de relais
notamment pour les adjoints par rapport
à différentes délégations
donc voilà tout ça c'est fait maintenant
on a bien entendu deux aspects le
premier qui est la gestion de cette
sortie de crise qu'on espère une sortie
mais du coup un travail pour une société
plus durable plus juste et puis le
deuxième aspect qui est ce projet
municipal validé à la majorité par les
habitants notre état d'esprit est celui
d'une opposition constructive mais
vigilante
c'est pour au cours du mandat il ya le
développement économique y a
[Musique]
la transition écologique parce qu'on là
dessus on a une approche totalement
différente en ce qui nous concerne pas
d'opposition entre
l'écologie et l'économie au contraire
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit tout à
fait l'optique de la majorité on reste à
magny les hameaux avec le déconfinement
les maisons d'hôtes ont repris leurs
activités touristiques pour certaines
structures la principale activité est
liée au voyage d'affaires et l'accueil
de personnes travaillant dans la zone de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est le cas
de maisons prairie bonheur qui a eu une
belle surprise en plein confinement le
récit de nicolas d'andry sur des images
de riom c'était en plein confinement le
15 avril dernier anne bonnassies reçoit
une demande de réservation d'une chambre
pour une semaine de la part d'un
espagnol en déplacement professionnel
depuis séville on avait plus personne et
plus d'activités et et lui voulaient
absolument il était indépendant il
voulait absolument continuer son
activité sur le golf national pour un
chantier avec le déconfinement les cinq
chambres d'hôtes et le gîte avec ses
deux chambres se sont remplis mise en
place des gestes barrières mises à
disposition de masques et de gel
hydroalcoolique
toutes les mesures ont été prises pour
accueillir les clients j'ai eu des des
queues de chantier qui
donc du personnel qui devait finir des
chantiers qui avaient été démarré en
janvier février mars et qu'il souhaitait
terminer leurs chantiers qui nous ont
sollicités pour séjourner ici sans
d'heure lui vient de belgique durant
toute la semaine ils logent dans cette
maison dans le cadre de son activité
professionnelle et de vanina ickx place
ce style c'est un très bon endroit parce
qu'après le travail
je suis peut prendre du temps pour te
reposer de ta journée le soleil est là
au jardin c'est un peu comme des
vacances après la journée de travail
dans cet établissement les voyages
d'affaires représente 80% du chiffre
d'affaires
la gérante a une bonne assise
s'inquiètent d'un ralentissement de
l'activité à partir de la mi juin
hormis les mesures de l'acte ii du
déconfinement la réouverture des musées
et monuments nationaux qui va s'étaler
sur un mois et demi selon un communiqué
du ministère de la culture qui donne un
calendrier prévisionnel le château de
versailles et son domaine devrait être
de nouveau accessible à partir de samedi
prochain le 6 juin
aucune information sur les conditions de
cette réouverture n'a été communiquée
pour l'heure elles seront publiées
prochainement sur le site internet du
monument
c'est un rendez vous phare chaque année
dans les yvelines qui réunit près de 3
millions de personnes
en deux mois la fête des loges n'aura
pas lieu à cause de la crise sanitaire
le maire de la commune de saint germain
en laye a rendu sa décision vendredi
dernier un coup dur pour les forains qui
a été reçu en mairie cet après midi
reportage de michael et demi d'euros et
de nicolas d'andré c'est une première
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale la
fête des loges qui devait se dérouler du
26 juin au 16 août n'aura pas lieu
le maire de la commune arnaud péricard
vient d'annoncer cette décision la
raison invoquée la crise sanitaire liée
aux coville 19
monsieur le maire nous a expliqué les
problèmes c'était sanitaires surtout
on est toujours en zone orange et que
c'est compliqué pour organiser le flux
d'entrée des clients la distance entre
chaque client l'organisation d'un tel
événement dans la forêt de saint germain
les aurait également un impact
économique important pour la commune
le coût de l'organisation est supporté
par la commune la perte pourrait
atteindre 700 mille euros cette année en
raison d'un format réduit sur la durée
comme sur le nombre de forains présents
de leur côté les fora accuse le coup
déjà frappé par l'annulation de la foire
du trône est propriétaire la traction et
les restaurateurs craignent la
banqueroute avec le report de cette 360
huitième édition
la plupart la part de revenus on n'a
rien du tout façon la lettre de l'état
mais elle a beaucoup qui ne touche pas
c'est compliqué il faut faire des
demandes des taux et puis il ya les plus
gros forains qui vont aller gros crédit
ils vont déposer le bilan
on sait pas comment ça va faire l'avenir
les organisateurs espèrent un retour à
la normale en 2021 chaque année la fête
des loges accueille près de 3 millions
de visiteurs et 200 attractions
pour refermer ce journal il sera de
nouveau possible de visiter entièrement
le zoo de thoiry à partir de demain
mercredi est la partie safari avait
rouvert aux véhicules depuis le 16 mai
c'est désormais la partie n'est acquis
et du site qui est de nouveau accessible
le zoo de thoiry sera ouvert au mois de
juin du mercredi au dimanche de 10h à
18h avec des mesures spécifiques est
liée au contexte toutes les informations
sur touahri planète
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité et très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]